[Music]
our show our show the Conan show has
been selected to premiere the trailer
for a big movie that's coming out this
fall this trailer has not been seen it's
titled Kingsman the Secret Service it's
based on the acclaimed comic book which
tells the story of Kingsman a British
spy organization that recruits a street
kid into the agency's super competitive
training program just as a global threat
emerges from and I'm quoting a twisted
tech genius I think all tech geniuses
are twisted
anyway it's a fresh take on the classic
spy genre with tons of action
lots of stunts and now the exclusive
broadcast premiere broadcast premiere
meaning television yes
television I don't know why I said that
I just I was told I have to say the
television and I want to point this out
television is still the number one media
on the island nation of Comoros okay
yeah so Kimora's go here it is the first
peek at Kingsman the Secret Service huge
IQ great performance of school but you
gave up
drugs
petty crime he never had a job
set you on a certain path
but you needn't stay on it who are you
the man who got your release I've never
met a tailor before I know you ain't one
come with me what do you see I see a
young man with potential pull the hook
on the other
oh yes very nice
what is this the electric you don't be
ridiculous it's a hand grenade
shut up that is sick we are an
independent international intelligence
agency operating at the highest level of
discretion
the Kingsmen ages other new nights you
are about to embark of the most
dangerous job interview in the world
felt sorry for the boy did you he will
find this humiliating he's as much
Kingsman material as any of them we're
here to enhance your skills testing to
limits we need to solve problems under
pressure like what to do when one of
your group has no parachute
interested
- make it man
have trouble understanding you people
sometimes y'all talk so funny
what about them what makes them so
special
put it back
[Applause]
[Music]
that is awesome that was really good all
right we'll take a break